L.A. IN 2012 AND 2014.
OUT IN FRONT.
CALGARY DOES A FWAUB DOING THIS.
YOU SAID IT RIGHT.
THE PUCK HAS EYES.
KUHLMAN SCORES!HE WALL.
THE PHONE IS RIN IS DOING THE R
WALL.
PICKED UP THAT TIME AND CLEARED
OUT BY VINCE DUNN.
STOLEN BY LINDHOLM. THE FLANK
GOES WIDE.
SHOT TAKEN ON
GREAT NEWS.
LIND THROUGH CENTER BY
EHIND THE NET AND
KEEPING THE PUCK DOWN LOW,
FORCING CALGARY TO PLAY DEFEN
GOURDE.
GOURDE SENDS IT TO THE NEAR
CORNER.
RASK WILL MOVE LINE CAN BE
AS FAR AS SCORING.
IT DOESN'TOR LEWIS ON THE DOORS
THE DELAYED PENALTY. GOING TO GD
FOR
TONIGHT WILL TAKE IT TO IN THAT
SCRAMBLE.
KOLE ENDS UP GETTING THE PUCK A
READY FOR THIS SAVE.
MICHAEL STONE INSIDE THE RING.
THE SECOND OPPORTUNITY TO  LUCI.
THREE OP TWO.
GOOD ONE ON HANIFIN.
TRIES TO GET IT UP AND OVER THAT
SHOULDER. IT.
COMES OUT OFF TANEV.
NOW WENNBERG TO THEBOX.
RASMUS ANDERSSON.
TOFFOLI'S IN FRONT.
THE T
MET THERE.
HE'LL TAKE IT IN.
OUT IN
A SCRAMBLING PUCK.
CK.
PENALTY HAS CONCLUDED.HAT SEATT,
GETTING THEIR PENALTI
OUT TO CENTER.
GOOD PASS FOR BACKLUND.
HIS SHOT BLOCKER DUNN.
MO MOVED ALONG BY WENNBERG.
HERE'S McCANN. IT OUT.
DUNN WALKS IT. AND CHARGE BY MO
GEEKIE.
HOT BOUNCE OFF THEE ZONE WILL CO
IT. ANY CHANCE THAT GETS
PUT COUNSEL AND CALGARY HAS